- [Instructor] The question
before us today is:
why were Mongols so effective?
How did they manage to take
an area, starting around here,
and over the course of
20 years during the reign
of Genghis Khan, from about 1206 to 1227,
expand from this little part of Siberia,
just south of Lake Baikal,
all the way into Central Asia?
This is what the Mongol
Empire looked like in 1206,
and this is what it looked like in 1279.
This here is Genghis-Khan time,
and this here is around
the reign of Kublai Khan.
What enables a spread of territory
on this scale in such a short time?
The Mongols were not a centralized state.
They weren't a centralized empire.
They were a band of traveling horsemen.
How did they end up taking this much land?
The story of the Mongols is a story
of a non-state actor
overcoming state actors,
of a decentralized power
becoming centralized eventually.
What I wanna talk about in this video
is three reasons why the Mongols were
so effective in beating
established empires.
And then we're gonna talk about some
of those follow-on effects.
Reason one why the
Mongols were so effective
was planning, what we
might call logistics.
When Genghis Kahn,
lemme pull up a picture
of good ol' Genghis,
when Genghis was declared Emperor,
or Great Khan, of the Mongols in 1206,
one of the first things he
did was reformat the army.
He swept away tribal
affiliations and favoritism.
If you were good, you got
to have a higher position;
if you were bad, you didn't.
This meant that ordinary
people within the Mongol army
felt that they could have a
measure of social mobility
if they performed
especially well in the army.
This made them very
committed and very loyal.
Reason number two: the Mongols
were extremely adaptable.
We're talking about a
group of horsemen here.
These are the Mongols attacking
a group of Chinese soldiers.
What they were used to was mounted combat
against mounted opponents.
What they weren't used to was attacking
major cities and holding them,
or even trying to get
major cities to break.
But what the adaptability
of the Mongol army meant
was that as they conquered new territories
and as they fought and won and lost
in various regions of
Asia, so, for example,
as they started conquering
the Western Xia here,
they learned siegecraft,
and that's the art of attacking
walled cities and castles.
It's a completely
different style of combat.
What it involves is
sitting outside of a city,
and waiting to starve out the inhabitants.
Part of it involves using these
things called siege engines.
This here is a kind of catapult.
You can see here the rocks.
The Mongols are waiting
with their archers here.
The opponents have arrows, as well,
but they're flinging rocks into the city
in order to force a surrender.
The Mongols didn't really
have this technology
or these tactics when they
began their military campaigns;
but as they rolled through
Central Asia they picked it up,
and then they continued
to use those tactics
as they swept westward.
Now, the third reason that
the Mongols were so effective
is because they were terrifying.
Even though they mastered siege warfare,
in the beginning at least,
the Mongols were not prepared
to hold a city once they had conquered it.
There are stories,
especially from the conquest
of the Western Xia and the Northern Song
and the Khwarazmian Empire over here,
that tell of the Mongols winning a battle
and then sweeping in
and murdering everyone.
Just pulling plunder from corpses,
and just looting the entire city,
and leaving nothing standing.
Because the Mongols weren't
especially interested,
at least early, we're
talking about the period
of Genghis Khan's life
here, so, 1200s to 1220s,
they weren't especially
interested in governing.
They wanted to hold
territory, and get tribute,
and get money, but they weren't especially
interested in running an empire.
It actually made more sense to them
to slaughter everybody
and take your things.
Now, it got to the point
that this reputation
for fearsomeness got so
powerful that some cities would
just give up and surrender the
moment the Mongols arrived.
Those are the three main
reasons that comprise
Mongol effectiveness
against settled states.
They were very good at planning.
Everybody rode in their armies.
They could move very quickly.
The Mongols were extremely adaptable.
Every time they lost,
they learned something
from the people they lost
to, and that meant that
they picked up new technologies
like siege warfare.
And they were absolutely terrifying.
Since, initially, the
Mongols didn't know what
they were gonna do with a
conquered city besides loot it,
they just killed everybody,
and that reputation
really allowed them to conquer
a lot of land very quickly.
And so we see out of the Mongol conquest,
there are many follow-on effects,
but one of the chief ones
is something called the Pax
Mongolica, the Mongolian Peace.
If that phrasing looks familiar to you,
it's because it's similar
to the Roman Peace,
the Pax Romana; and the Chinese Peace,
the Pax Sinica of the First Century CE.
This is 1100 years later, but
the same principle applies.
What happened was, with all
of this territory conquered
under one ruling power,
it became safe to travel
from one end of the empire to the other.
Indeed, this is exactly what
Marco Polo did when he set off
from Venice, and made his
way, eventually, to Beijing.
That would've been around this time.
Marco Polo's book, The Book
of the Marvels of the World,
was published in 1300.
Marco Polo was this Venetian
trader and adventurer
who traveled extensively throughout Asia.
That's one result of the Mongol conquests,
is this Mongolian Peace.
I should say that this Mongolian Peace
came at a terrible price.
When we were talking about
that terror of the Mongols,
that's a for-real thing.
They murdered millions of people.
But what would come
after the Mongol Conquest
as a result of this peace
would end up killing
even more people than the
Mongol Conquest itself.
This pacified region,
this Mongolian Peace,
led to increased trade
throughout East Asia
and reconnecting it to
Eurasia and the Arab States.
That would result in the
exchanges of new ideas
and new technologies and
new agricultural techniques.
But, as trade always does,
it also results in the
exchange of diseases.
And so, out of the
Mongol homeland, in fact,
comes this illness
called the Black Plague,
or Bubonic Plague.
Because of the stability of trade
that had been established
by the Mongol Peace,
it makes it so much easier
for this illness to sweep
across Asia and Europe,
killing even more people than
even Genghis Khan could've
achieved during his lifetime.